Optimal at this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile before my hands start shaking.
I'm a cybernetic organism.
This episode of the Tim Ferriss show is brought to you by 99 designs and ex
officio.
99 designs is the world's largest online marketplace of graphic designers and I
have used 99 designs for years,
including to get cover concepts for the four hour body,
which went on to become number one New York Times Number One Wall Street
Journal.
It was a huge shit and here's how it works and you can check everything out,
including some of my competitions.
You can see these book covers and so on@ninetyninedesigns.com forward slash Tim,
whether you need a logo,
a car wrap,
a web design and APP,
a thumbnail,
a tee shirt,
whatever.
You go to 99 designs.com you describe your project and then within a week or
less you have tons of designers around the world who compete for your business
and submit different ideas and designs and drafts.
You have an original design that you love or you pay nothing.
It is fantastic.
I have used it.
I have mentioned it before,
including in the four hour work week as a resource.
Check it out,
99 designs.com forward slash Tim and if you use that link,
you'll be able to see what I've done on the platform.
You will also get $99 as an upgrade for free,
which will get you more designs,
more submissions.
So check it out.
Ex-Officio boy,
where do I begin?
I have a long history with ex-officio.
Ex-Officio makes clothing and as far back as 2007 2008 I had a hit video that
went viral called how to travel the world with 10 pounds or less.
And I talked about ex-officio underwear.
Ex-Officio underwear is lightweight,
ultra lightweight,
quick drying and antimicrobial.
Why is this important?
Well,
I've gone through 20 plus countries with two pairs of underwear before,
both from ex-officio,
and I'm not alone in this.
This might sound crazy,
but a lot of executives,
for instance,
we'll take this underwear,
they'll wash it in the sink or somewhere else,
roll it up in a towel,
like a Burrito step on it,
and a few hours later they are completely dry,
completely clean.
You don't have to just have to,
and yes,
they have to be comfortable for all day wear,
but check out their clothing as well as their underwear.
You can go to ex-officio dot com forward slash Tim that's x,
C I o.com forward slash Tim and you can see this video which has a bunch of
other packing tips,
but this underwear,
this clothing is not just for the gents ladies.
You have choices too and they really have an incredible collection of high
quality products that I've used for almost 10 years now.
So check them out.
Ex-Officio dot com forward slash Tim.
Hello Ladies and germs.
This is Ferriss,
yet again,
running out the door to a flight.
But I have such an exciting episode.
I can barely contain myself.
I might just,
we myself on my way across the country,
but I digress.
Probably Tmi.
Let me answer it.
Just a couple of questions.
What does this podcast about you long term listeners might know longterm long
time that it's about dissecting excellence,
trying to tease apart what makes world class performers so good at what they do.
Finding the tools and tactics that you can apply in this episode.
Features Maria Popova.
I'm about to explain who she is and if you don't know who she is or if you are
intimately familiar with who she is,
you're in for a treat.
First I'll answer a question that a lot of people ask me and that is what are
you reading?
Well,
what I'm reading right now is two books comprised of two books.
The first is William Goldman Adventures in the screen trade.
Goldman is the screenwriter behind such movies as the princess bride,
one of my favorites of all time and butch Cassidy and the Sundance kid.
The second book is John Muir wilderness essays,
so very different.
Both very,
very good and highly recommended.
The adventures in the screen.
Trade is a little outdated with some of the contents because it's related to
film and it was written in the 80s but there are a lot of timeless principles
and Goldman is just hilarious,
but moving on the guest,
Maria Popova,
oh my goodness,
where to start.
She would describe herself as a reader,
writer,
interestingness,
hunter gatherer and curious mind at large.
What does that mean?
It'll all make sense in just a few seconds.
While she's written for all sorts of amazing outlets like the Atlantic and the
New York Times,
I find her most amazing project to be brainpickings.org and I'm not alone in
this.
Founded in 2006 as a weekly email that she sent out to seven friends,
coworkers,
really very informal.
Brainpickings was eventually brought online and now it gets more than 5 million
readers per month.
It is massive.
Many of you ask,
what blogs do you read often,
what do you do online?
Where do you spend most of your time?
The answer is that I read very few sites consistently.
I don't have that type of loyalty,
but brainpickings is one of the few,
it is a treasure trove.
It is Maria's one woman labor of love,
her subjective lens on what matters.
It's also an inquiry into how to live and what it means to lead a good life.
This is what hooks me of course,
because she'll pull from excerpts and reading from the Stoics,
my favorite Seneca to mark Twain,
Oscar Wilde,
and everyone in between.
Uh,
Maria is good at finding the hidden gems to share and the amount of information
this woman consumes and camp can parse down to the finest detail of what will
help you.
Now blows my mind.
She makes me look like the laziest son of a bitch ever.
Uh,
and of course immediately my questions are how,
how does she do that?
How on earth does she do that?
And we dig into this in this interview.
Really,
I try to unearth the hidden gems in her life,
her workflow,
it takes me a few minutes to warm up as it often does,
but once we get going,
we geek out like crazy and we talk about almost every aspect of her life,
her site,
her business,
her workouts,
her writing,
her workflow,
her tools,
her work arounds,
all of it.
And I love doing this interview.
I hope you love listening to it.
And for bonus credit,
for those of you who are super curious,
might have a little bit of extra time to do some detective work.
At one point she mentioned that her Facebook fan page went from a few hundred
thousand people to over 2 million people without explanation.
So if you are able to figure out why that happened,
what contributed to that?
Please let me know.
On Twitter at t,
Ferris,
I'm dying of curiosity and always,
or as always I should say the show notes,
all the links that we mentioned,
the tools,
et Cetera,
all of that can be found on the blog at four hour work,
week.com,
forward slash podcast,
four hour workweek.com,
forward slash podcast all spelled out.
So you don't need to scribble away furiously with notes.
Uh,
all that you can,
I will have pretty much everything that you will need right there in the show
notes.
So without further ado,
please meet Maria Popova.
Hello Ladies and gentlemen,
this is Tim Ferriss and welcome to another episode of the Tim Ferriss Shell.
I am extremely excited to have a fellow Geek in arms,
Maria Popova on the line with me.
Maria,
how are you today?
Very well,
thank you.
Thank you for having me.
And I appreciate your coaching on the last name,
I wasn't sure if it was Popova or Popova.
I have friends who,
for instance,
[inaudible] has a friend.
It's actually novel,
but Americans can't really pull that off.
So he goes for Nevada all.
So I appreciate the coaching and I,
yes,
as a country of immigrants,
we have a surprisingly hard time getting people original names.
Right,
right.
Yeah.
Oh,
absolutely.
It's,
you know,
just the sort of anglicizing of,
of such a,
uh,
curry sorta like a,
a melting pot of different cultures and you know,
it at the same time,
I think it's a reflection of where I spend a lot of time,
uh,
which is reading and there are so many words I've embarrassed myself on many
occasions that I've read dozens or even hundreds of times,
especially in scientific literature that I've never heard pronounced.
Yeah.
Plus reader syndrome as somebody who spends the majority of her waking hours
reading,
you run into that a lot,
especially with,
um,
sort of cultural icons,
last names,
first names that are spelled differently than,
very differently than their pronouns.
It's kind of tragic comic when you actually find out how they're pronounced.
No,
exactly.
Or it can be a real revelation.
I remember when I was a,
uh,
a kid,
I couldn't hit,
let's say democracy or aristocracy.
I could only say because that,
and I'd also read it,
uh,
you get a demo Krassi Aristo Krassi for whatever reason I couldn't get the
emphasis right.
Uh,
but coming back to the,
the reading and someone who spends most of their waking hours reading,
uh,
if,
if someone asks you,
and I'm sure occasionally it happens,
you'll,
what do you do for those people listening who may not be familiar with you,
but we'll start with a cocktail question.
When someone asks you,
what do you do?
How do you answer that?
Well,
I've answered it differently over the years in part because I think inhabiting
her own identity as kind of a perpetual process.
But right now I would say I read and I write in that order and in between I do
some thinking and I think about how to live a meaningful life basically.
And if someone were to go online,
find your work,
end up at brain pickings and they're like,
oh,
this is quite interesting.
What kind of looked over their shoulder because they happen to be doing it on
their iPhone at the party.
And they're like,
what is brain pickings?
How would you describe,
how do you typically describe that?
It's just a record of that thinking.
My personal subjective private thinking that takes place between my reading and
takes and the writing and takes form in writing
collection of very interesting things.
And sometimes you know,
how I can sort of simply put it to folks and brain pickings for those people
wondering is one of the very few sites.
Then I end up on constantly.
And when people ask me,
what blogs do you read?
I,
I'm embarrassed in some cases kind of humiliated to answer that I don't go
really too many blogs consistently.
Um,
and I think part of the reason is so many of them are feel compelled to put out
very,
very timely of the moment material that expires within a few hours.
And I don't like the feeling of,
uh,
keeping up with the is when the Jones's or just sort of churning out content.
And I remember Kathy Sierra at one time at one point told me that you should
focus on just in time information,
not just in case information.
Uh,
and which I thought was very astute and really sort of profound.
But there are,
there are two sites that come to mind that I end up on quite a lot.
Brainpickings is one,
uh,
and Sam Harris blog yeah.
Is another,
uh,
and I saw your,
your review of his latest book Waking Up,
not a review,
not a review.
I don't review books I bought.
Okay.
No,
this is no,
so this is this annotated reading if they're well,
okay.
So an annotated reading of a,
and I definitely want to dig into that annotated reading of waking up,
which I found really,
really impactful me in a lot ways.
It,
it put words to a lot of vague sort of feelings or observations that I had for a
very long time.
Uh,
talking about reviews.
So I pulled a number of my friends and my readers about different questions they
would love to ask you.
And a close friend of mine,
Chris Saka,
uh,
he,
he came back with what percentage of New York Times bestsellers can be
attributed to your coverage.
And I'd be curious to hear you answer that.
And then there's sort of a followup,
but you've,
you've built this incredible powerhouse of,
uh,
an an outlet for your,
whether it's creative musings or observations and it has a,
a huge influence on what people read.
So if you were to sort of think of that,
how would you answer that question?
Well,
first of all,
you,
you're very kind to put it that way as a script.
But I think one big caveat to all of that is that the majority of books that I
read and write about,
or very old out of print,
uh,
things that are not competing for New York Times bestseller.
In fact,
I don't even know if I ever really,
I mean perhaps,
um,
I dunno if the books that I read have any overlap in the venn diagram of things
with the New York Times bestsellers.
But I suspect that the reason Chris asked that question is actually that I met
him through his wife who collaborated with Wendy McNaughton,
the illustrator whose work I love.
And I love Wendy on a book about wine.
And that book ended up,
I and I wrote about it because it's lovely and sort of profound and um,
challenges or existing ideas about sort of sensory experience.
And I like things that that takes something very superficial and find something
deeper and something unusual.
And it's uh,
but in any case,
so I wrote about that drug in that particular piece on green pickings seem to do
pretty well.
And I think perhaps that warp tour
of how much
contemporary books I really sort of am interested in.
Um,
but,
but I would say that's a minority,
right.
And for those people wondering,
it's the essential scratch and sniff guide to becoming a wine expert,
which has written along with,
and the illustrations are,
are wonderful.
Uh,
the Richard,
that's his,
the Somalia who is part of that.
And at one point I met with him because I wanted to try to uh,
deconstruct the master,
some lea test and he said,
I can show you how to do it.
And it was just the paired down sort of hacked,
if you will,
version still of passing the masters familiar taste was so intimidating that put
it on ice indefinitely.
But at some point Richard,
we will talk again and uh,
and,
and form a game plan.
The,
so the,
the opposite of course of sort of putting out this material that expires as soon
as it's out on the vine is uh,
putting out what I think you do very often and that is sort of timeless,
timely and timeless.
I've heard you call it material where you're sort of pulling from old sources
are older sources,
uh,
doing pattern recognition to pull from other areas to talk about say a a theme
or,
or something that still affects people.
And uh,
I was,
I was doing research for this interview and uh,
you know,
we've,
we met briefly in New York at an event and I've been a longtime fan of your
work.
And so I thought to myself like,
you know,
how much,
how much digging do I really need to do?
And Good God,
you have such an absolute cannon of work out there.
It is astonishing.
I mean it is really,
I find it's just the volume of time really.
It's been,
you know,
I've been doing this for eight years,
coming up actually exactly.
A month from today,
it'll be eight years.
Cumulation you know,
and I,
so I was,
I was,
I'm fascinated by routine and schedule and uh,
you know,
I'm reading from,
of course not,
not the always accurate,
but generally a good place to start Wikipedia and,
uh,
it says that brain pickings takes you to 400 plus hours of work per month,
hundreds of pieces of content per day,
12 to 15 books per week that you're reading.
Uh,
how do you,
and I,
I'm,
I know I'm asking a handful of questions that you've been asked before,
but sometimes the answer is change and evolve.
They always do.
And which is why I actually don't do interviews very frequently because I find
that they sort of
tend to kind of cast this as this static thing that just stays there is some
sort of reference point.
While we're really just the fluid process and we're constantly evolving.
But in any case,
no,
definitely.
So what do teens do?
The question that you've,
I'm sure been asked many times,
but I'll ask again is how do you choose the books?
How do you find slash choose the books that you read?
This is a huge problem for me because I,
I,
my,
my appetite for reading outstrips the time that I have.
And so I ended up actually,
uh,
unfortunately sometimes finding myself anxious because of the number of books
I've taken on it at any given point in time.
So I'd be curious how you sort of vet the books that you read.
Well,
I guess it goes back to that question of,
well,
let me backtrack and just say that I write about a very wide array of
disciplines,
an era as and sensibilities because that's what I think about too.
And the thing from art and science to philosophy,
psychology,
history,
designed poetry,
you name it.
But the common denominator for me as just this very simple question,
does this eliminate some aspect,
big or small of that grand question that I think we all test the lid everyday,
which is how to live well,
how to live a good,
meaningful,
fulfilling life.
Whether that's,
you know,
Aristotle's views on happiness and government or beautiful art from 12th century
Japan or,
or Sam Harris's new book.
Anything.
Got It.
And the,
I've read you citing Kurt Vonnegut,
uh,
before,
on,
against one of my favorite writers of all time.
No,
I heard you're a Semicolon,
right?
I think it was
either the interview I did with Kevin Kelly or with Sam,
but I actually have a counterpoint to the semicolon.
Okay.
No,
no,
go on.
So I actually,
uh,
I actually beat,
I brought up the semi colon quote partially as a sort of wink,
wink,
nod,
ribbing to a friend of mine named John Romanello who has a tattoo of a semicolon
on is,
I think it's his fault.
He left some type nerd.
He loves semi colons.
He also has a molecule of testosterone on the other armies.
He's a fascinating guy.
But,
uh,
the,
the quote that I heard you site that I wanted to dig into a bit was the Kurt
Vonnegut saying,
right to please just one person.
And so my question to you is,
when you write a,
is that still the case?
And if so,
who are,
who are you,
who is that person that you are writing for?
It does very much the case.
I still write for an audience of one and that's myself.
It's like I said,
it's just a record of my thought process,
my way of just trying to navigate my way through the world and understand my
place in it,
understand how we relate to one another,
how different pieces of the world relate to each other.
And students create a pattern of,
of meaning out of seemingly unrelated meaningless information and the sort of
intersection of,
or transmutation of information into,
into wisdom really,
which is what learning to live is.
It's about Lisbon.
Um,
so I,
and,
and it's interesting too because when I started writing things,
like I said almost eight years ago,
it started very much as a private record of my own curiosity.
And I shared it with seven coworkers that I had at the time,
just as a little sort of email newsletter thing.
Um,
and now to think that there are about 7 million people,
strangers reading it every month,
that's amazing.
But,
and I'm not sort of number dropping for sale or anything like that,
but just to try to articulate how surreal it feels to me that I still feel like
I'm writing for one person,
one very sort of,
you know,
inward person.
But there's also now the awareness that there are people looking on and
interpreting and,
and just relating to this pretty private act.
And it's a strange thing to live with and,
and no way a,
a bad thing.
I'm not complaining about it obviously,
but it's just interesting to observe how,
how one relates to oneself when being looked on by a few million people.
You know.
Definitely.
And uh,
there's so many,
it's so many questions I want to ask you.
We might have to do part two at some point because I know we have some time
constraints,
but the uh,
the where to even begin,
this is where my,
I start fraying at the ends as an interviewer.
So the,
the,
the first question would be related to that.
There's so much temptation to dumb things down or to go after kind of the tried
and true buzzfeed type headlines.
Uh,
do you ever contend with that temptation?
And if,
if so,
how do you resist it?
And I ended,
this is part of the,
you get,
how do you respond to the,
the expectations of the crowd or the 7 million people looking on,
and I feel this personally sometimes because I have a blog.
It has,
it's certainly by no means the number of monthly readers that you have.
Um,
you know,
I'm somewhere between one and 2 million uniques a month usually.
Uh,
but thank you.
But even at that point,
even though that scale,
there are times when I put out something that I feel is very,
it's very important,
but on the dense side and,
and then it will,
sometimes it takes off,
but,
but sometimes it doesn't.
And,
and there's a lot of temptation when,
for instance,
I know you use social media quite a bit and we'll get to that where I look at
say the retweets,
the favorites on something that's kind of dense and then I'm like,
Oh God,
I should just do like the seven tricks you can,
you can actually teach your cat,
you know,
and get 500,000 retweets.
Um,
is that something that,
that you're,
that ever sort of crosses your mind and do you ever feel that temptation?
Okay.
Well,
you know,
it's interesting because I think anybody who thinks in public,
which is what writing is,
which is even what art is,
it's some sort of
putting a piece of oneself out into the world.
Anybody who does that struggles with this really irreconcilable kind of tug of
war between wanting to really stay true to one's experience.
You know,
and being aware that as soon as it's out in the world,
there is this notion of the other audience.
And you know,
Oscar Wilde,
he,
uh,
very memorably said that I'm a true artist,
takes no,
not noticed whatever of the public and that the public art to him,
nonexistent.
And it's very easy to say,
especially for somebody as Wilde who was very prolific,
very public,
almost performative in his public presence.
It's very easy to call this out as a kind of hypocrisy and say,
well,
you can't possibly not care about the audience even you make your living through
it and sort of perform to it.
Right.
But I,
I think that's a pretty cynical interpretation.
I think rather than hypocrisy.
It's just this very human struggle to be seen and to be understood,
which is why
all art comes to be because one human being wants to put something in it to the
world and to be understood for what he or she stands for and who he or she is.
And so with that Lens,
I do think it's hard to say,
well,
you know,
I don't care about what happens to it out there,
even though I write for myself and think for myself,
the awareness of the other really does change things.
But I think perhaps Werner Herzog put it best that I just finished reading this
kind of 600 page,
um,
interview with him.
Essentially it's a conversation that I'm a journalist named Paul Cronin had with
him over the course of 30 years.
And in one passage,
um,
Herzog says something like,
you know,
it's always been important for me to,
um,
have my films reach an audience.
I don't necessarily need to hear what those audience reactions are just as long
as they're out there that they're touching.
The films are touching people in some way.
And I feel very similarly.
So with that in mind,
I guess to answer your question,
rather circuitously I don't feel quote unquote tempted to make listicles or to
make anything that I feel compromises my experience of what I stand for and
import.
I think the beauty of the web is that it's a self perfecting organism,
but for as long as it's an ad supported medium,
the motive will be to perfect the commercial interest.
So perfect.
The Art of the Buzzfeed Listicle,
the endless slide show,
the infinitely paginated article and not perfect the human spirit of the reader
or the writer,
which is really what I'm interested in.
No,
it's a
very virtuous goal.
I,
um,
I really admire your site and obviously the newsletter and all these other
aspects of it,
uh,
for a lot of reasons.
Uh,
one of them is,
uh,
well I,
I feel a very sort of kindred spirit with a lot of the decisions it seems you
have made.
So for instance,
I mean not doing the,
the slideshows to rack up page views for some type of advertising.
That stuff drives me insane.
So if it drives me insane and I assume it drives my readers insane,
so I'm not going to do it.
Or like you said,
yeah,
so wonderful that you do that because I think so much of that cultural crap that
is out there,
not just in the Internet,
just in general,
comes from people who failed to understand that they should be making the kind
of stuff they want to exist.
So if you're a writer,
write the things you want to read.
If you're an artists,
paint the things you want to pick me you want to see painted.
And I think the commercial aspect is really warping that.
And I really,
one thing I really admire about your work in all of its permutations from your
books too,
you know,
this podcast,
the say everything,
is that there's just this sort of sense that you just want this to exist.
It doesn't exist for any other reason than you want it to exist.
And I think that's wonderful.
Thank you.
That means a lot to me.
And I uh,
you know,
coming back to the,
the right to please just one person.
It's,
I,
I think that it's,
it's related to that.
So in a way it's,
you know,
put the things out into the world that you would want to
consume yourself or experienced yourself.
Number one.
Secondly,
just for those people who,
who haven't,
I heard this anecdote when I was reading the four hour workweek is my first
book.
I've,
I still to this day find writing very challenging and I wish I could say it's
gotten easier over time,
but for whatever reason it seems not to have,
uh,
the,
in the case of the four hour work week,
I,
you know,
came out of Undergrad at Princeton and many,
many years have passed.
I'm asleep.
But when I wrote the first few chapters,
it was really stilted and pompous and kind of Ivy League,
you know,
where I was trying to use $10 words where a 10 cent word would suffice and be a
lot cleaner.
So I threw out the first few chapters that I drafted and this was a major panic
attack moment.
I was on deadline.
And,
uh,
I remember I was in Argentina at the time.
Uh,
and then I went the other way and I said,
no,
I have to be loose.
I have to be funny.
And so I wrote a few chapters that were completely slapstick,
ridiculous.
I mean,
they,
it sounded like three stooges put on paper and so I had to throw out those few
chapters and of course I'm doubling down on my anxiety at this point and uh,
decided at one point that I was just going to have a little bit of Yerba latte t
two glasses of wine and no more than two glasses of mall back and sit down and
start to write.
What is that?
Uh,
Malbeck is just this wonderful,
versatile in South America,
uh,
best known in Argentina,
but there are actually some really nice malbeck wines in Chile.
They were,
as I understand it,
it was viewed almost as a garbage grape in Europe,
but it was brought by the Italians to winnow side days and has developed this
worldwide fame because of its cultivation in Argentina.
So there's,
there's a lot of sort of,
there's a lot of metaphor there.
Then I also like,
but drink two glasses of wine,
sat down and literally opened up an e an email client and started typing the
four hour work week as if I were writing it to two of my closest friends.
Uh,
one was,
uh,
an investment banker trapped in his own job and he felt like he couldn't leave
because his lifestyle was swelling to meet his income.
And then the other was an entrepreneur sort of trapped in a company of his own
making.
And so these two very specific guys in mind,
I started to write with just enough alcohol to dissertate the edge off.
And that's how,
uh,
the,
I was writing in that case to please just two people.
Uh,
but that's,
that's the only way I could make it work.
Uh,
the,
uh,
your schedule.
So I've,
I,
I've read of your schedule,
uh,
but I,
I'd love to hear the current iteration of that.
It seems like you,
you've had a fairly,
you have a fairly regimented schedule,
which would make sense if you're putting the number of,
of hours into reading and writing that you do.
So what is,
what is your current day look like?
Well,
I'll answer this with a caveat.
The one thing I have struggled with or tried to solve for myself in the last few
years,
couple of years maybe as the student,
really delicate balance between productivity and presence and especially in a
culture that seems to measure our worth or marriage or value through our
efficiency and our earnings and our ability to perform certain tasks as opposed
to
just the fulfillment we feel in their own lives.
And the present is that we take in in the day to day.
And that's something that's like a more and more apparent to me.
So I'm a little bit reluctant to discuss routine as some sort of holy grail of
creative process because it's just really,
it's a crutch.
I mean routines and rituals help us.
Yeah.
Not feel like this overwhelming messiness of just day to day life with
consumers.
It's a control mechanism,
but that's not all there is.
And if anything,
it should be in the service of something greater,
which is being present with one's own life.
So with that in mind,
my day is very predictable.
Um,
I get up in the morning,
I meditate between 15 to 25 minutes before I do anything else.
What time do you wake up typically
exactly eight hours after I've gone to bed.
So it varies.
Okay.
Um,
I'm a huge proponent of sleep.
I think,
um,
I,
when I write because what,
or when,
I guess tried to think what I do is essentially make associations between
seemingly unrelated ideas and concepts.
And in order for that to happen,
you know,
those associative chains need to be firing.
And when I am sleep deprived,
I feel like I don't have full access to my own brain.
Um,
which certainly I'm not unique in that in any way.
There's research showing that the are reflexes are severely hindered by lack of
sleep were almost as drunk if if we sleep less than half the amount of time when
normally need to function.
And I think
ours is a culture where we,
where we,
um,
where our ability to get by on very little sleep as a kind of badge honor badge
of honor,
the speaks work ethic or toughness or whatever it is,
but really it's a total profound failure of priorities and have self respect.
And I tried to sort of enact that in my own life by being very disciplined about
my sleep,
at least a disciplined as about as I am about my work.
Because the latter is a product of the capacities,
you know,
cultivated by the former.
Um,
so in any case,
so I get up eight hours after I have gone to bed,
I meditate.
Um,
I go to the gym where I do most of my,
um,
longer form reading.
Uh,
I get back home,
I had breakfast and I start writing.
I usually write between two and three articles a day and one of them tends to be
longer.
And when I write,
I need uninterrupted time.
So I try to get the longer one done earlier on in the day when I feel much more
alert.
Um,
so I don't look at email or any,
anything really external to the material I'm,
I'm dealing with,
which does require quite a bit of research usually.
So it's not like I can cut myself off from the internet or from other books,
but,
uh,
I don't have people disruptions I guess.
So anything social.
Um,
and then I take a short break.
I'm a believer in sort of pacing,
um,
creating a sort of rhythm where you do very intense focused work for an extended
period and then you take a short break and then cycle back,
you know?
Um,
and then I deal with any sort of admin stuff like emails and just taking care of
errands and whatnot.
And I resume writing and I write my other article or articles through the
evening.
I try to have,
um,
some private time,
just later in the day,
either with friends or with my partner or just,
you know,
time that is unburdened by deliberate thought.
Oh,
though you can never unburden yourself from thought and general.
And then usually later at night I either do some more reading or some more
writing or a combination of the two.
Got It.
And so a number of follow up questions.
What type of meditation do you practice currently?
Just guided Vipassana.
Very,
very basic.
Um,
there's a woman named Tara Brock who,
um,
she's a mindfulness practitioner.
B R,
a,
c h.
Got it.
And she's based out of DC and she,
um,
was trained as a cognitive psychologist then the decades of Buddhist training
and,
and lived in an Ashram and now she teaches mindfulness has been with a very
secular lens.
So,
um,
she records her classes and she has a podcast,
which is how I came to know her.
And every week she does a one hour lecture and sort of the philosophies and
cognitive behavioral,
you know,
wisdom of the ages and then she does a guided meditation.
Um,
so I,
I used her meditations and she has changed my life perhaps more profoundly than
anybody in my life.
So I tried to be highly recommend her.
Um,
Tara Brock,
Brock,
yes.
And all her,
her podcast is free.
Um,
she has two books out to,
um,
she's really wonderful,
very generous person.
I'll have to check that out.
And a c you're listening then you have earbuds in when you are doing or you're
listening,
you're listening to audio while you meditate.
Yes.
And it's interestingly,
I mean she puts one out every week,
but I've been using the exact same one from the summer of 2010.
It's just one that I like and feel familiar with and it sort of helps me get
into the rhythm.
So everyday I listened to the right
2010.
How does that start?
How would people recognize it?
How does the audio
tidal is,
it sounds cheesy but it is not cheesy.
I think it's called smile meditation.
Uh,
and I'm sure she has repeated it in various forms through the years.
In other recordings,
you just happens to be the one that I,
you know,
have on and on.
My broken three g iPhone without any internet or cell service,
which I just use as an iPod.
Awesome.
That's great answer.
Um,
God a love.
I love digging into the specifics.
And when you go to the gym then,
uh,
to workout,
are you still using an elliptical for that or are you,
are
I do sprints,
time testing,
intervals on the elliptical.
And Are you getting your cardio and I do a lot of weights and body weight stuff
too.
You do?
All right.
But when you're reading,
is that on the elliptical?
Yes.
And what type of a device,
if any,
are you using for that reading?
Well I prefer electronic,
so I use the kindle app on the Ipad or any pdf viewer cause I read a lot of
archival stuff.
But the challenge of course with it,
because I read so many older books that are out of print,
let alone having digital versions,
that's not always possible in case it's rarely possible unless I'm writing about
something fairly new.
And so in that case I just go there with my big Tome and my sticky notes and
pens and sharpies and areas,
annotation,
analog devices and I just do that.
Cool.
All right.
So that leads perfectly into the next question,
which is what is your note taking system?
Look like and how do you take notes?
So for instance,
uh,
you're really good at using excerpts or quotations,
pull quotes.
And I found myself asking as I was reading this,
like how,
how are you gathering all of this so that you can use it later.
Um,
so what is your note taking system look like when you see in the case of digital
and in the case of hard copy?
Yeah,
so when digital,
um,
it's very simple.
I just highlight passages and I write myself little notes underneath each year,
um,
that are,
that have acronyms that I use frequently for certain topics or shorthand that I
have developed for myself.
Uh,
but reading is really,
or understanding really is below in reading should be a conduit to,
is a form of pattern recognition.
So when you read a whole book,
you kind of walk away with certain takeaways that are thematically linked and
they don't usually occur sequentially.
So it's not like you walk away with one in section one,
the first chapter one is it from the second chapter.
It's just sort of this pattern of the writers thoughts that,
that,
that permeated the entire narrative of the book.
And so,
especially as you,
if you read as a writer,
so somebody who not only needs to walk away with that but ideally wants to
record what those patterns and themes are.
That sort of reading is very different.
And so what I end up doing with analog books in particular,
and it's sort of hacked him systems of doing it electronically but they're
imperfect,
is add on the very last page of Ad Age book,
which is blank usually right before the end cover,
I create,
uh,
an alternate index.
So I basically list out as I'm reading the topics and ideas that that seemed to
be important and recurring in that volume.
And then next to each of them I start listing out the page numbers where they
occur.
And on those pages I obviously highlighted the respective passage and they have
a little sort of sticky tab on the side so I can find it.
Um,
but it's basically a,
an index based,
not on keywords,
which is what a standard book index is based on,
but based on key ideas.
And I use that then to sort of synthesize what those ideas are once I'm ready to
write about the book.
Okay.
I have to geek out on this because I'm so excited now.
So is it turns out with analog books,
I do exactly literally exactly the same thing.
I usually start with the in front inside cover,
but I create my own index and of course they don't have to be an order.
So you can sort of list them in any way in my particular case,
in any,
any order.
Um,
I also will have sort of a to
a couple of have lines dedicated to Ph and ph just refers to phrasing if I find
a turn of phrase or wording that I find really great.
Do that.
Oh,
really?
Okay.
B L for beautiful links.
Oh,
that's so cool.
Okay.
So there's that.
And then I have,
um,
uh,
you know,
like Q or Q if I,
if their quotes.
So,
for instance,
many books will have quotes attributed to other people or just Hetero quotes,
uh,
in some cases.
And so I'll have,
um,
you know,
quotes all,
just write that out.
And then colon and then I'll,
I'll list all the page numbers for that particular sort of category that I'm
collecting in the case of quotes.
So for when you're gathering this,
you mentioned acronyms and a shorthand.
So besides beautiful language,
what are some of the other acronyms that you use?
Oh,
they wouldn't make that.
They're just very private.
It's like too long to get into what they stand for.
Is there one other example that you just,
just,
if you could indulge me?
One that is,
I guess not so much about the contents of that passage as it,
as about its purpose is LJ,
which is,
I have a little sort of labor of love side project called litter and jukebox.
Right?
Sure.
I've seen it.
It's,
yeah,
it's,
it's awesome.
Oh,
thank you.
But yeah,
so I do these pairings of passages from literature with at the magically matched
song.
And so sometimes when as I'm reading a book,
I would come across a passage that I think would be great for that and maybe a
song comes to mind and so I would put LJ next to,
but I want to go back to what you said about the external quotes.
I guess the author quoting another work.
I think those are actually really important and that goes back to your question
about how I find what to read and I mark those types of things.
So for the,
for the annotations that are specific to that particular book,
all of my sticky tab notes are on the side of the,
of the pages.
But when there's an external quotes,
something referencing another work,
I put a tab at the very top with the letterF ,
which stands for find.
If I am not with the word the work or just no letter.
If I just want to flag a from something else that I know of.
And I think that's actually very important because
the,
the phenomenon itself,
not my annotations of it,
because literature is really,
and I say this all the time,
it is the original Internet.
So all of those references and citations and illusions,
even,
they're essentially hyperlinks that that author placed to another work.
Um,
and that way if you follow those,
you go into this magnificent rabbit hole where you start out with something that
you're already enjoying and liking,
but follow these tangential references to other works that perhaps you would not
have come across that way.
Uh,
I mean directly and in a way it's a way to push oneself out of the filter bubble
in a very incremental way.
And I've often found amazing older books that were,
you know,
five or six hyperlink reference says removed from something I was reading,
which led me to something else or something,
make something else,
which led me to this great other thing.
Um,
so I think that's,
that's kind of a beautiful practice.
Yeah,
it's a,
the,
the serendipity of it is so beautiful when it works out.
And I'll,
I'll,
uh,
give a confession.
This is really embarrassing,
but you know,
since you know,
is listening.
Uh,
I came across Seneca Seneca,
the younger who's had probably more impact on my life than any other writer.
Uh,
it originally,
because there I,
I was perusing it,
a number of anthologies on minimalism and simplicity and Seneca kept on popping
up,
quote Seneca,
quote,
Seneca.
And because it was always one word like Madonna
or,
and this is going to be really embarrassing,
or like sitting bull,
I assumed that Seneca was a native American elder of some type for probably a
good,
well,
yeah,
I assumed he was a native American elder for a probably a good year or two
before I realized he was a Roman.
I was like,
man,
Ferris,
you gotta do your homework pal,
like,
get to dig in.
And then at that point is when I really sort of jumped off the cliff into all a
lot of his writings,
which I've,
I still to this day revisit on an almost
revisited,
um,
his,
the shortness of life.
Oh,
so good.
So is this perhaps the best manifesto?
And I hadn't had this modern word,
um,
sort of buzz word,
but I use it intentionally.
So the best manifesto for our current struggle with this very notion of,
you know,
productivity versus presence and how much are we really mistaking the doing for
the being,
you know,
and,
and it's amazing that somebody wrote this millennia ago before there was
internet before there was the things we call distractions today.
And yet he writes about the exact same things just in a different form.
Yeah.
The exact same things.
And the way that,
uh,
if I'm trying to use Seneca is a gateway drug into philosophy.
I won't use the P word first of all with most people because philosophy smacks
of,
I think it calls to mind for a lot of people.
The hottie pompous,
uh,
college student in,
um,
uh,
goodwill hunting in the bar scene,
who's like reciting,
you know,
Shakespeare without giving,
uh,
any type of
completely disagree.
No,
I agree with the notion that those are its connotations today and people have a
resistance.
I think that's all the more reason to use it heavily and to use it
intelligently.
And to reclaim it and to get people to understand that philosophy,
whatever form it takes is the only way to figure out how to live.
Everything else that we take away from anything is a set of philosophies
essentially.
I agree.
No,
I totally agree.
So,
but I usually,
if I'm going to lead people there,
I try to,
to,
to lure them.
You are the man with,
with Seneca because I think he's,
he's very easy to read compared to a lot of st least the Stoics,
uh,
or,
or that's actually not even fair compared to a lot of philosophers who,
who had been translated from Greek.
Most of his writing and believe is translated from Latin,
which tends to be just an easier jump from English.
So,
um,
it's very easy to read night.
What I tell people is,
you know,
start off with some of his letters and you'll find that you could just as easily
replace these Roman names like Luke Ileus and s and so on with like Bob and Jane
are,
you know,
pick your contemporary name if a of choice and it,
they're all as relevant now as they were then.
Um,
so I,
I'm going to come back to the sort of performance versus presence,
which I think of oftentimes as the sister of achievement versus appreciation,
uh,
split or balance or maybe neither.
But before we get there,
I want to put a,
put a bow on the note taking with your electronic note taking.
So you're using the kindle APP,
you're taking highlights.
Where do you go from there?
Are there any other,
what is,
what is the sort of workflow look like from there?
And are there any,
any,
uh,
particular types of software or apps or anything like that that you use often?
I mean,
honestly,
I feel like that problem has not been solved at all in any kind of practical
way.
So the way that I do it as basically a bunch of hacks using existing
technologies,
but I don't think,
or perhaps I'm just unaware,
but I don't think there's anybody designing tools today for people who do
serious heavy reading.
There just isn't anything that I know and see what I do is I highlight in the,
in the kindle app on the Ipad,
um,
and then,
Amazon has this function.
Then you can basically see your kindle notes and highlights on the desktop or on
your computer.
I go to those,
I copy them from that page and I pays them into an Evernote file,
um,
to sort of just have all of all of my notes in a specific book in one place.
But sometimes I would also,
um,
take a screen grab of a specific iPad,
kindle app and kindle page with my highlighted passage and then email that
screen grab into my Evernote email because Evernote has,
as you know,
optical character recognition.
So right when I searched it,
it's also going to search the text in that image.
I don't have to wait until I finish the book and explored all my notes.
And,
and also it's,
the formatting is kind of shitty on the,
on the kindle notes on the desktop,
we can see all your notes.
So if you copy them,
they paste it into Evernote with this really weird formatting.
Uh,
so it tabulate each next notes in dented to the right.
So it's sort of this cascading long cascading thing that shifts more and more to
the right.
Right.
Moved down.
Horrible.
It's like an email thread.
It's like an email thread except there's no actual hires.
You,
these are all,
you know,
and so if you want to go fix it,
you have to do it manually within Evernote.
And you know,
I read,
you know,
on on the Verner Herzog books for example,
which is 600 pages,
I have thousands of notes.
So imagine thousands of tabulations until the last one is so narrow and long
that it's just like unreadable.
So hence my point about just there is no viable solutions that I know.
Got It.
Okay.
So let me just,
because I,
I,
this may or may not help for me,
it was a huge shift in how I manage Evernote because that may mean I'm looking
at this list of questions.
Um,
and I'm not reading entirely offset on script,
but I have a collection of questions in Evernote right now.
And one,
one of the things I realized about formatting and transposing things from say
the,
you know,
my kindle page,
if you,
if you log into your,
your Amazon account through kindle.amazon.com or I'm copying pasting from many
different places is going to,
I don't know if you've tried this,
but edit and either paste and match style or paste as plain text and it tends to
remove all of that headache.
Um,
let's see,
nine times out of 10.
So if you,
yeah,
if you have a problem with that,
I did try that once.
But when you remove the style,
it makes all the metadata look the same as the tech.
So I may be highlighted passage.
I also have my own notes.
I see.
Got It.
Plus,
plus,
you know,
Amazon's own thing that says add note,
read,
redid this location.
And so it all merges it and become just hideous.
It's just an awful today.
No,
I wonder,
I wonder what to do there.
Yeah,
I used to take notes and drop them into text wrangler,
which is used for coding a lot just to remove the formatting and then put it
into every,
yeah,
I do that with Cota.
Yeah.
Yeah,
it's true though.
There there's gotta be a solution.
And the thing is Evernote.
I love it.
Evernote,
I've been using it so many years and I could probably not get through my day
without it,
but it hasn't Api,
which means somebody can build this,
you know,
in a sure way to like,
I even thought,
I mean,
I was at one point so desperate and so frustrated,
which I think is the,
you that causes all innovation,
you know,
desperation and frustration.
I thought maybe I should just save up some and offer,
uh,
like a scholars or like a grand for a hackathon for somebody to solve this for
me.
You know,
that's a great idea.
I mean,
I,
I'm still sort of contemplating that.
Okay.
We'll,
we'll,
we'll talk about that separately.
I think that's something that we could absolutely explore it for all of you
programmers,
coders out there,
please take a look.
This is actually not as rare issues you might expect.
One question for you on the kindle highlights,
uh,
because I've run into this,
you mentioned the Werner Hertzog book and having,
you know,
thousands of of highlights I've have,
you run into instances where your,
you're reading an entire book,
you're super impressed or not,
but regardless you have hundreds of highlights and you go to look at those
highlights and you're restricted to only see,
yeah,
the Fred like 200 highlights,
81 available.
Right?
So how often does that happen to you?
Because that's happened to me where I've taken so much time to meticulously
highlight stuff and then I'm only able to see a 25% and it's so infuriating.
And I think it's a limitation that is determined by the publisher.
Yes,
it is.
And so I'll tell you why.
It hasn't happened to me much.
It happens to me occasionally,
but that's a DRM saying digital,
sorry,
listeners who don't like acronyms,
digital rights management,
uh,
thing that has,
that is fairly new.
So that is the case more recently published books,
right?
But if you read,
you know,
the digitized version of say,
you know Alan Watts,
it was published originally 40 years ago.
There's no such problem unless the publisher now is like reclaiming rice and
doing a whole new thing.
But because I read so much less out of sort of newly published material,
I don't run into it often,
but you know,
there is a way to very laboriously,
you know,
deal with it,
which is you can still open that passage in your kindle app on desktop.
So kindle for Mac for me and it will let you highlight and copy those passages,
paste them into your Evernote in between the missing courts.
But it's obviously the Nazis.
I have done that and it's so horrible because you also get the like excerpted
from Dah,
Dah,
like three lines,
everyone.
So just publishers,
if you're listening to this,
you are making it harder for people like Maria.
If 7 million uniques per month to share your stuff.
So pleased up your threshold.
Uh,
okay.
Do you have anybody helping you with brainpickings or is it just you?
Um,
the actual reading and writing,
obviously it's just me,
but as of about 10 months ago,
I have an assistant Lisa,
who's absolutely wonderful when she just helps me with admin stuff that has to
do with my travel or email or scheduling things that I feel is weighing me down
so much.
I operate so much out of a sense of guilt for sort of letting people down or,
and as you know,
I'm sure when you get to a point where the demands are just incomparable with
what you can even look at,
then you kind of need to have help in order to not to either go insane or live
with a constant guilt over not addressing things.
So,
and was there a particular,
oh,
and I also have a copy editor.
This wonderful older lady I hired to do my proofreading.
Um,
she's great.
I am,
that's all I can say.
I think proofreading is really,
really important and I'm constantly embarrassed if I have a Typo,
which you know,
as you know,
as a writer you cannot prove your own work.
Just your brain just does not see any
errors that we've made in the first place.
What were the majority of them?
And so
people are kind of mercy,
Lowe's,
they think somehow that a typo makes you lazy or I hadn't even know.
There's no kind of compassion for the humanity that produces something as human
as a Typo.
Right.
Despite how mechanical the term itself seems,
which is sort of ironic,
but in any case,
so yes,
I have my assistant for Admin and my copy editor for just proofing
and what,
what platform is,
is uh,
bring takings,
uh,
onto the moment.
What does it,
what's the technology pond is?
I knew that,
uh,
I've heard you mentioned wordpress before.
Is it on,
is it still on wordpress?
Uh,
it is on wordpress.
I was going to make a joke about how the technology is called Corpus callosum
technology.
Yeah.
Very Sam Harris,
a friendly joke.
Um,
the,
uh,
so when you're working with say a,
your copy editor,
uh,
do you give your copy editor admin access to wordpress and she'll go in
proofread it and then schedule or publish,
what's the process?
It's,
it's a very,
again,
the pursuit of hacked together process,
which is every night I emailed her the articles from the preview page on
wordpress.
I just copy that and paste it into a body email and I send it to her and then
she sends me the correction to your email.
Got It.
I mean like I said,
she's not very,
I would say tech savvy.
I mean I'm sure she's a wonderful learner so I'm sure she would totally learn
how to do it if I gave her admin access.
But between that and the fact that I write in html,
so I really don't like the wiziwig.
I hate it actually.
I think it's just easier to do it via email because then she can like highlight
the word and sometimes she would make suggestions that are more stylistic.
And I,
I would like to have the final say in cause it's very often I want to keep it
the way that I have it because that's just my voice.
Um,
so I find email works just fine.
Got It.
Okay.
No,
I'm,
I'm always fascinated because I will use while when I was,
when I was hosting wordpress elsewhere,
I'm also in wordpress.
I would use the share a draft plugin to share drafts with people.
Uh,
I'm,
I'm now on wordpress VIP,
which has a,
it has a sharing function where people can leave feedback in a sidebar that runs
alongside the article itself,
which is pretty cool.
Well,
I should,
I should look into that.
I think that's what I have to their work.
Presby I see the wordpress hosted for press.
I don't even know what the function is.
So I,
I'm kind of,
I mean for somebody who writes on the web,
I'm,
I don't really,
yeah,
I sometimes only learn about things through friends.
Well,
I think,
yeah,
that's,
that's how I learned about a lot of this stuff.
And the,
the other option that I've used quite a lot is,
and as much as I hate word and I really do,
I love the track changes feature and I just find it more user friendly for a lot
of folks and then having them use something that's cloud based like a Google
docs just because I operate so much offline to try to get anything done.
Yeah,
I mean that's what a lot of people suggesting what Chi my appropriate or
actually asked originally,
but I do not own Microsoft products on principle.
Cool.
And I just said I'm not gonna deal with it.
Okay.
No that makes sense.
And your assistant,
what was,
what was the,
the the sort of defining moment,
the straw that broke the camel's back when you were like,
you know what?
Like what was the day where you just like fucking enough of this,
I need to get somebody's stat.
I mean,
what,
when did you actually make the decision?
It wasn't so much that I made the decision and the decision was very
strongly,
lovingly,
but strongly sort of pushed on me by my partner who one day said you are using
so much time on things that are just so menial and you should not cause I was
really stressing to a point of just driving myself crazy.
And I think a lot of it has to do with the fact that I'm always have been very
independent.
I moved away from my parents house when I was 18 pray my way through school,
lived always by myself and it just had this Emerson like,
you know,
sad self sufficiency and self reliance that to a point of pathology where it was
to my own detriment.
And the notion about sourcing felt to me on some level,
um,
almost like an admission of weakness.
It's ridiculous.
I feel,
I feel like people though,
I know.
And,
and it's the strange thing,
the disorienting thing is that I think we intellectually know that's not the
case,
that actually a lot of strength to be able to delegate and just sort of divvy up
control according to a hierarchy of priorities.
But on some sort of cycle emotional level,
it is just death to,
to consider that you cannot do something on your own anymore.
And of course,
I mean it's interesting in terms of how Branco things of all would.
She has always been very organic.
So the,
the sort of,
you know,
eight year thing that has happened,
it went from being a little newsletter that contains five links,
no texts,
like five links to five things that I found very interesting.
Um,
and then it went to sort of five links with a little paragraph about each about
why this thing is interesting and important.
And then it was,
you know,
not,
not a little paragraph but a little like one page piece.
And then it became not one,
not five things every Friday,
but three things every day of the week.
Pretty long form in the thousands of words,
you know,
and I foolishly and they easily dog that I could just have the same sort of
operational framework despite the enormous swelling of,
of just the volume of the writing.
And that's unreasonable.
It's completely unreasonable.
Um,
so at one point last fall as the sort of seventh birthday of brainpickings was
approaching,
my partner was just like,
eat pleased.
It's like consider and uh,
yeah.
Hi,
I'm sorry.
I didn't mean to cut you off.
I was just,
I'm always curious to ask,
how did you,
how did you find this,
the assistant that you ended up with?
Uh,
well,
she's wonderful.
She's a professional sort of personal assistant that's had this type of jobs or
that 20 years.
Uh,
she's just a wonderfully warm and,
and just generous person,
but also has such doggedness about things and just work ethic.
It's unbelievable.
And you always have the sense that she's looking out for your best interest in,
in the most magnanimous kind of way towards you,
but also the most warmly non no bullshit way outwardly towards the world
demanding things from you and having this buffer.
It's really,
really great.
Yeah.
And did,
uh,
was she,
how did you track her down?
How did the two of you get connected?
Uh,
just a recommendation she's been working for,
um,
somebody who is a very trusted dear person for a long time.
So now she works in both of us.
And did that person reach out to you?
Did you reach out to her?
I'm always curious about the specifics because of the way that I found one of my
first assistants and we worked together for many years was anytime I had a
really fantastic interaction with someone's assistant,
I would say,
Hey,
I know this is off topic,
but you've been awesome to deal with.
Do you have,
you know,
a twin brother,
twin sister,
somebody who does what you as well as you do at that you could recommend to me
cause I need some help.
And I just did that over and over again.
And eventually one of the said,
well actually I worked for multiple clients so we can talk about it.
And that's how we ended up working together.
Uh,
but what,
what was the,
the introduction was made by the person.
So we,
I had met her,
at least in my assistant,
had met her just socially many times before.
And so eventually when the time came for me to consider,
um,
like she just like we set up a meeting,
we talked and she was really into it and she had been reading brain pickings and
uh,
um,
I asked,
made sure it wouldn't be too much on her plate.
Cause she's also,
I mean,
she's super woman,
Lisa superwoman.
She is the mother of two kids,
one of whom is now her first year in high school and the other one his first
year in college.
So I see that on her plate too.
And uh,
uh,
but she's very,
like I said,
very dogged,
very sort of dedicated.
And she was like,
I can get it and uh,
I'd like to do it.
And I was like,
great.
Let's roll
onward with,
uh,
with your assistant.
If you were to do in 80,
20 analysis of to the,
the,
you know,
the 20% of tasks that take up 80% of her time.
What,
what are the types,
what would those look like?
What does the vast majority of her time spent on?
A lot of it is I guess coordinating travel and things,
but I'm trying to really,
I mean I have this new ish commitment to really not do any speaking at
commercial conferences anymore,
but to speak to students because I think it's important and um,
what it takes out of me,
which is a lot speaking takes out a lot of me because I'm a writer and I also
don't really recycle talks.
Um,
I like to write something original and when it's a commercial conference,
it just doesn't add up for me what I get out of it.
Cause I usually donate my commissions due to the local public library and
whatnot.
But with students,
it is worth my time.
If I this way,
even one journalism student from going into buzzworthy lands,
you know,
after graduation,
that's worth it to me.
And so even though I've scaled back on the speaking,
speaking,
I now getting like all these college requests.
And so that takes too much time,
especially coordinating because a lot of them are organized by sort of student
volunteers and they're kind of still learning what it means to,
you know,
schedules and deadlines and advanced notice.
And so it releases sort of wrangling that.
And another big part,
and I should also mention that the evolution of what I've been able to delegate
has been,
has sort of organically happens.
Originally I just really didn't know what to give her.
I felt like I had to do all of it cause I didn't know how to explain it to her
to do.
And,
but she's a great learner and I'm learning to delegate more.
But another thing,
because my site runs on donations,
I want to,
I sort of make an effort to send a handwritten thank you cards to just at this
point randomly picked donors every month.
Um,
and so I have her sort of export those names and emails for me and just give me
like,
just prepare envelopes and all those types of things.
The deck is not spend too much time on the actual admin of the mailing.
And do you operate,
do you communicate exclusively via email or do you use a soft other types of
software?
Oh,
email,
email and text,
email and text.
So no project management software at this point?
No.
Sort of base camp or a sauna or anything like that?
No,
I don't.
I,
that would make me feel like I'm some sort of commercial organization,
you know,
I still have so much resistance to the fact that even have to deal with these
things,
that Fascia,
that Oscar Wilde,
hypocrisy audience,
humanity,
I guess at the tension.
Uh,
what's,
um,
a couple of,
a couple of quick ones.
So the first is when you,
when you lift,
do you tend to have the same workout?
What do you,
what is your,
what is your weightlifting look like
changed a lot in the last year and a half?
I've prioritize bodyweight stuff heavily,
no pun intended.
That was actually total inadvertent.
This how language,
how we think in language.
That's so funny.
Uh,
but,
uh,
I,
I prioritize bodyweight stuff and so I do pull ups,
pushups and that sort of thing.
Um,
it also depends on where I do my work.
Had My gym,
has my building,
has a sort of gym,
like,
uh,
you know,
one of those residential gyms.
Uh,
but I also have a membership at a larger,
um,
probably I think the best gym in New York.
I love it,
but I'm only there a few days a week.
So it just depends on where I do it and what I do.
If you had to pick one besides the elliptical,
if you had to pick one body weight exercise to hold you over,
let's say you're traveling for a few months,
you can only pick one body weight exercise,
what would it be?
Well,
it wouldn't be pull up,
but you can't always find a place to do it.
So I just do usually elevated pushups,
so my feet on a bench or bed or some like a step or something and just push ups.
Cool.
A great little hack for pulling motions while traveling is putting your feet on
a chair and going underneath a table to do basically inverted bent rows,
uh,
to,
you know,
it's actually very helpful for traveling is a plyometrics,
plyometrics and a TRX is actually quite handy.
There's a sort of system
for some reason it just not my thing.
You can't get into it.
Yeah.
The thing is,
here's the thing.
So if I am forced by circumstances to do a workout,
that is not my preference.
I very much like to be able to do something else while doing it,
such as listening to podcasts,
which is what I do well while I do weights at the gym anyway.
Um,
and there are certain types of movements that it's just a hassle to have the
headphones and it was just like not great.
Sure.
So I actually carry a,
um,
waited jump rope with me when I travel in case there's no,
or to do sprints,
which is my plan B for Cardio.
And then plan C is just jumping,
skipping rope.
Yeah.
You're intense.
I love it.
The,
uh,
I remember the,
the,
uh,
you know,
I wanted to,
every time I meet,
and this is so silly,
but I was so obsessed with a Bulgarian Olympic weightlifters for very long time,
that whenever I meet Bulgarians are people who in at any point have lived in
Bulgaria.
I want to talk about Olympic weight lifting,
but it's not,
I know nothing about them.
I don't know exactly your wait staff when I was living area.
No,
exactly.
It's kind of like,
uh,
you know,
like,
Oh,
you're from Switzerland,
let me talk to you about the guys in the Rico look commercial.
They're like,
no,
we don't talk about that stuff.
Um,
yeah.
Is that guy your cousin?
Yeah.
Right,
right.
You must know like,
no,
I actually don't like,
I know I went to the x,
Y and z college,
but there are 5,000 people per year.
It doesn't,
it doesn't always work out.
You mentioned the donations.
I want to talk about the site.
So
it appears,
and I,
and I dug around a bit,
but it appears that you have no comments or dates on your posts.
Is that accurate?
I don't have comments.
I do have dates there.
And then you're out.
Oh,
they're in the URL.
But they're not in the post there in the URL structure,
but they're not in the displayed post itself.
Yeah.
So the reason for that is because I do think we living in enormously news
fetishistic culture.
And the reason I do what I do is precisely to decondition that because we think
that if something is not news and it's not at the top of the search results or
the top of the feed because all feeds or reverse chronology,
then you know there's an implicit hierarchy of importance to that.
We think if it's not at the top,
it's not important.
And you know,
you would understand,
you know,
writing about Seneca,
it really doesn't matter with a date stamp on it is.
But I think that this culture conditions is so much people when they see a date
stamp,
they sort of think,
oh,
this was like two years old.
Oh and it's really,
you know,
2000 years old.
But because a lot of backlash
[inaudible] actually use brain pickings to reference.
So I constantly get things,
this is another thing that leaves to deals with like request from textbooks or
citations or you know,
whatnot.
And those people actually need the dates.
So I've made it so that if you actually look,
it's kind of easy to to see or I can just tell them it's when they rights and
asked me what the date is,
look in the URL,
but it's just not one of those immediate things that slaps you over the head,
like a newspaper front page.
You know?
Definitely.
I actually have done the same thing for quite a few years and if you,
if you go to any permalinks so if you go,
if you get linked to any of my posts directly on the blog,
the date is there in the URL,
but also,
uh,
at the very bottom of the post after the related links.
So for the same reason,
because there's so much bias against older material.
And I think some of my older stuff is,
I mean it depends on the person obviously in the context,
but,
um,
it's,
it's an easy way to have a high sort of abandonment rate is to,
to timestamp the comments.
Did you ever have comments or have you never had comments?
And then I was like,
you know what,
I kind of feel like Herzog does.
I don't really care to hear.
I mean,
I do write for me,
I'm,
I'm very gladdened by people who are in any way moved or touched a,
but the comments I was getting,
I was,
I've been fortunate enough not to really get any,
you know,
trolling or anything like that,
but they were kind of bacon or people trying to plug their own thing or spam and
it was taking more of my time that was worth.
And so instead of made my contact information very easily accessible.
So if someone has something of substance and urgency to say,
which is I think that two things that compel people to reach out,
uh,
they'll do it via email,
behind their own name and not anonymously.
And then,
I mean I do get a lot of,
a lot of emails from readers,
um,
and those are valuable,
you know,
but I don't really care for comments.
Now the flip side of that is that now that I have the Facebook page having
something mysterious happened with the brain pickings Faisal page last fall
where it just started growing so fast.
I've no idea why
I was going to ask you about that because if you,
if you look at say that your Twitter follower growth versus your Facebook
groups,
the Facebook just kind of took off.
Yeah,
it was in about October of last year and it went from 250,002 now I think,
I don't know,
I think it's close to three maybe so more than 10 fold in less than a year.
I have no idea why I've done nothing differently.
I'm very,
I don't really enjoy Facebook.
I do it reluctantly because I know I get a lot of emails from readers,
um,
elsewhere in the world who actually use Facebook as their primary thing and
they're such sweet notes,
you know,
people who just are stimulated and inspired and moved in a way that perhaps they
wouldn't be if they hadn't read that piece about some random thing that I read
and wrote about.
And I think it would be selfish of me to just sort of disabled Facebook because
I hate it.
But the,
the point of it is that you can't,
you have comments on there.
And Lisa,
my assistant,
actually,
that's something I delegated her a few months ago.
Uh,
just to completely deal with them.
I can't,
I can't deal with them.
I can't.
And,
and not for any other reason that I have complete allergy to people pronouncing
their so called opinions without having actually digested or even engaged with
the thing.
So people would comment on the basis of like a thumbnail image or the title make
really outrageously inaccurate comments.
Clearly not having read the piece and this kind of snap reaction thing that I
think social media to a large extent perpetuate.
I can deal with it.
It just,
it,
it's like a psychic drain.
Like I can't even explain it.
Just,
I can't.
So anyway,
so that would explain,
that would answer one of my questions,
which is in your header picture on,
uh,
Facebook you have,
this should be a cardinal rule of the internet and of being human.
If you don't have the patience to read something,
don't have the Hubris to come.
Yeah,
care if it's a town like bitsy or anything,
the point,
I mean,
you know,
it's interesting because I think a lot about criticism and the notion of
criticism and,
and why it's so hard for anybody and I,
I don't think that people have a hard time with criticism because another
person,
this agrees with or dislikes what they're saying,
they really have a hard time when they feel misunderstood.
Like the other person does not understand who they are or what they stand for in
the world.
900% of the time.
And you actually touch on this in your conversation with Sam Harris will just
say that his ideas are not as controversial as people think when they don't
actually understand what they are.
Right?
But the main source of anguish is not being seen for who you are,
not being understood.
And this kind of reactive culture where people comment without taking the care
to understand what you're expressing,
who you are,
what you stand for.
It is so toxic.
It is so toxic to readers,
to writers,
to us as a culture.
And I just don't know how to get around it other than just having instructed
Elisa to be just merciless about banning people and deleting comments that are
just not,
there's no humanity,
there's no patients,
there's no thinking in them.
So I mean,
he,
you know,
anybody who writes online,
I think feel similarly that this is kind of my home.
And if that's what people come and be idiots in it,
then they're not welcome there.
So
yeah,
no,
I actually used the exact same analogy.
I say,
look,
I've,
you might,
especially on my blog,
I've used the comments is my living room.
And if you come into my house for the first time and get raging drunk and like
take your sh,
you know,
put your feet up on my table with your shoes,
you're not going to be invited back.
You're gone,
you know?
Um,
so is,
is your assistant's job as it relates to Facebook then primarily calling the
herd and just removing the,
the idiots or does she have it?
What are,
what are other instructions,
if any?
Are there things that she passes to you?
Are there things that she responds to?
No,
I don't.
I don't really care what people say.
Again,
to the point that if people have something substance and urgency,
they will reach out.
And I'm then very happy to hear from actual humans and engage in a human
dialogue,
which I do,
but I don't really care about,
you know,
the comments on Facebook.
I just don't want them depressing me when I go on the page because I put my own
thing.
You know,
Lisa doesn't put the actual postings and I also don't want them creating a
culture that is antithetical to the very reason why I do what I do,
which is a kind of faith in the human spirit.
I mean that's where I come from.
I am a cautious one sometimes,
but an optimist about the so called human condition and anybody who craps on
that without having him and given a chance to the thoughts that,
that speak to the,
the to those ideals,
which is what my articles or record at then I will want them gone,
you know?
And so her instructions or just,
you know,
band people who are offensive to others sort of in a vicious way as opposed to
just having rational discourse of disagreement,
a band,
people who are ignorant and,
and have not read the thing and have some very scandalous or anything,
not even scandalous sort of contrarian sensation was take on it.
Clearly not understanding the nuance because I mean a culture of news is I say
often a culture without nuance then um,
yeah.
So that that's basically,
it helped me stay sane when I look at them.
That's her,
that's her task,
not fake.
You lose my mind over exasperations when people was impatient.
No.
And I,
you know,
I really respect that because,
uh,
another reason that I read,
brain pickings as opposed to other sites and I feel comfortable going there is
that I feel it is sort of a stronghold of positivity and optimism,
uh,
in,
in a lot of respects.
So kudos.
The email,
uh,
actually before we get the email,
I've read that you schedule your Twitter and Facebook,
which would make sense because you're prolific.
Uh,
if that,
if that's still the case,
what do you use to schedule that social media?
I use buffer for,
um,
uh,
Twitter and I use my hands for Facebook.
Yeah.
Um,
but again,
I mean this goes back to the same inner struggle of I do want to be reading and
writing for myself.
So why do I have the compulsion to put so much of it out there?
And I just sell flagellate over that because on some level it does seem like a
form of hypocrisy.
But then I do think about the people that email me from India and Pakistan and
South Africa and Korea and we're wherever,
that actually,
that's how they connect.
And I think if I'm putting in the amount of time that I do into,
into what I do,
even if I do it for myself,
I might as well just harness that time anyway if it benefits somebody else's
journey,
you know?
And so I do it because of that mostly.
Definitely.
And I think that while it's fun to write for yourself,
if you,
if you keep the value of what you write to yourself when it could benefit a lot
of other people,
then I think that's actually,
it could be viewed as a selfish act.
Right?
So the,
I think,
yeah,
I think that there's,
particularly when you're curating and the way that you do and you're saving
people thousands of hours of searching by distilling a lot of these concepts.
Um,
well I would argue that the benefit,
the value is not even,
I mean,
what I do is kind of the antithesis of search.
It's a discovery of things that ideally one would not have come across within
the usual parameters of once filter bubble.
Right.
So sort of a lot of the people that that I hear from,
for example,
you know,
just this week two two's the Seneca example.
Actually just this week I heard from this guy who was an it person,
trained as a physicist,
end up doing it and said the Seneca,
the shortness of life piece really,
really put everything in perspective.
I've never really read philosophy,
never been interested in it,
never looked for it,
but it's just cut in the middle of what I'm struggling with right now in my own
life,
you know,
and it's kind of,
it gives me pause to hear that from people.
Definitely agreed.
Uh,
on a,
on email the,
if you go to your contact page,
you recommend email charter.org and I'm very curious to hear if people actually
follow the email charter e liquid.
Would you,
in terms of the,
the email that you receive,
um,
do people actually pay attention to that and for,
yeah,
they do.
And I'm so grateful and I mean,
but the majority of them do,
you know,
some people who reach out with the intention of self promoting there.
There's usually,
you know,
laziness to people who self promote for the sake thereof,
so they don't,
they don't usually,
um,
follow.
But people who actually care to have a conversation and to engage are very
courteous and very sort of mindful of what I've asked,
except for publicists who are never.
Yeah,
right.
Well,
I mean,
I suppose if they're flying on autopilot and just blasting out a template,
do your blow,
dear blogger.
Oh yeah.
I love it.
It's the deer blogger.
Yeah.
You know what I did very often,
which I think is actually hilarious,
uh,
people who don't even bother to read the name of the site,
so they address me,
dear Brian,
right.
Pinnacle of this was when last year,
at one point I opened my physical mailbox in my building,
my home and I found this bundle from the USPSA like with an elastic band around
it,
of mail for somebody named Brian Pekins who lives in Long Beach ca or
do I get
some how that stuff got forwarded to me because I guess the guy either moved and
the you sps,
like somehow look things up.
I didn't even know.
It was such a sort of mystery and metaphor for what I deal with that.
Yeah,
you don't have good public first.
Not Too.
So I used to have a company ages ago called brain quicken,
a
telemarketing call when evening.
And uh,
guy goes,
hi,
sorry if I'm interrupting,
is this Brian?
And I go,
excuse me?
And he goes,
Brian,
Brian Chicken.
And I'm like,
I'm Brian Chicken.
I was like,
Eh,
no.
And take me off your list to goodbye.
Uh,
the,
um,
oh God.
So on the,
on the,
uh,
on the email in pitching side of things or just on the pitching side of things,
how on earth do you deal with,
not just cold inquiries,
but how do you deal with writer friends or acquaintances who are writers that
you don't want to be rude to,
who want you to read their books?
How do you polite decline that stuff and maybe maybe you don't get a lot of it.
I get a ton of it.
And the fact of the matter is like not everyone is,
is able to put the time or effort into writing a good book.
So inevitably if I get 10 books from decent or good friends,
some of them are going to be terrible and I don't have the time to certainly or
the inclination to read them all.
How do you deal with that type of situation?
Well,
I guess the deal first and foremost by controlling not the outcome but the,
the cause,
which is your circle of friends and acquaintances.
I'm very selective about the people I surround myself with.
And,
um,
I like to think friendly to pretty much everybody that I need.
But my circle of actual friends is really close and really tight and people who
are just,
you know,
when the sky crumbles are going to be there and we're there for each other.
And so with that in mind,
I think there is a certain boundary they have to put up beforehand to to,
to I guess manage social expectations in a way.
Um,
and so for those people,
my friend friends in large part,
I mean I should mention that the majority of my close friends,
including my partner to,
or people that I've met just through what I do.
So there's already the self selection of sensibility and ideals and you know,
I think would become a centripetal force for the kinds of people we want to be
in,
surround ourselves with those types of people.
William Gibson has a wonderful word for it.
He calls it personnel.
Microculture uh,
and even when you said early on the kinship of spirit,
I think that's so important.
So,
which is the long winded way to say that when and if those inner circle people
put a book out,
it's a guarantee that I will like it because of who they are.
And so then I'm more than happy to support it.
I mean the,
the book that we started with the scratch and sniff guide to whine when d the
illustrator is precisely that type of person.
Somebody who I met through what each of us does and she's now one of my closest
human beings,
you know?
And so of course I'm going to support her work,
but not because I'm being um,
nepotistic about it,
but because that's the pre requirement that I am moved by her work and respect
it and love it.
And that's how we became friends.
But outside of that inner circle,
I don't,
I think acquaintances know that there's no such expectation and when I do get
such requests,
it's a matter of,
well,
did the person do their homework and knowing what I actually think and write
about,
because very often I'm sure he had that to get pitched.
Things that are just so outside of what you do,
in which case I don't even feel compelled to respond because if they didn't put
in the time to understand what I'm interested in,
why should I put in the time to explain to them why this is not a fit?
Yeah,
that's a great way to put it.
I need to embrace that more.
I think that's an area where I carry a lot of guilt.
Guilt.
Yeah.
It's interesting because guilt is kind of the flip side of prestige and they're
both horrible reasons to do things.
So often we would agree as humans,
not just you and me or just anybody would agree to do things because they sound
prestigious is in some way,
you know,
and,
and equally avoid things because of the guilt thing or do things because guilt
thing.
But sort of the whole Buddhist thing about a version of,
you know,
avoidance and aversion and making decisions based out of either fear,
which is what guilt is.
It's the fear of disappointing somebody and then feeling disappointed in
yourself or out of,
um,
sort of grasping for approval or a claim,
which is what doing things for prestige is.
I think either of those are really bad reasons to do things and yet they
motivate us a lot or at least they sort of lurk in the back of the mind
constantly in it.
And it is a real practice to try to decondition that.
Definitely.
No,
I like,
I like what you said about,
uh,
why put in the effort to explain why it's not a fit if they haven't done the
homework to determine if it is a fit.
I think that's a great way to put it.
Um,
I want to ask,
uh,
and I know we don't have too much time left,
so hopefully sometime someday we can do a follow up part two.
I think that'd be a blast.
I'll bring some mall back if you actually,
I can introduce you to at firsthand,
but the,
the donations,
I'm very fascinated by,
uh,
the,
the ad free donation approach and uh,
just just to,
to keep it simple.
If you had to choose,
um,
say 20% of the options you're currently offering,
which would you choose and why?
In other words,
you have people do that.
Yeah,
no,
no.
So I'll,
I'll explain.
Or two or three.
So you,
so people can make one time offer,
they can make a one time single contribution.
Uh,
they can,
uh,
let me simplify that question.
Or they can become a member and donate,
you know,
seven,
three,
10 or $25 a month.
Um,
what I'm trying to ask without being improprieties or making you feel
uncomfortable is what is working best.
Uh,
and when you're asking people for donations,
you know,
assuming that it's working,
uh,
if someone were to offer one or two options instead of four options per month,
or the,
the single contribution versus the membership or the membership versus the
single contribution,
what would your advice be to people?
Hmm.
Well,
I will preface this with a caveat that I use paypal for donations and I can't,
for the life of me figure out how to actually like,
look at the data and get any sort of real reason.
All of it.
It's so antiquated,
their export tools and such.
And I'm not that interested in,
I would slicing,
you know,
days into looking into it.
So I can tell you sort of my intuitive interpretation is yeah,
great.
And by the way,
the only reason these options are as they are also,
it is also the reason why I don't have an ad supported site,
which is I just asked myself,
what would I like to read as a reader?
Well,
I would like an ad free site and how would I like to support that?
I'd like to have a few options,
you know,
just because I don't want to,
being sort of confined to something.
And so I just just pull it out of the hat basically with these tears and I've
just left them on since they put them on.
They seem to work,
you know,
whatever.
And um,
originally my sense was that the one time donation is accounted for much more,
but I'd never actually analyze it because I think I see the alerts that come
from paypal and sometimes people would send really large one time donations.
Like things that are totally humbling and enormously generous.
And I think those kind of you,
you kind of weighed them somehow.
It's more,
um,
then the cumulative,
some of the smaller donations.
So I thought the one-timers work much more,
but then,
and I'm pretty sure that must have been the case earlier high,
right?
Uh,
but,
and I've had the recurring ones,
I found a onetime donation for as long as I can remember for as long as they
basically need it to start making money for the site.
Because by the way,
running the site cost me several times my rent,
like all the costs associated with it,
it's like crazy.
So at one point I got to a point where I had to make money.
I said,
I don't want to do ads.
I don't believe in that.
I'll have just donations.
And I didn't even think of recurring ones at the time.
That was years ago.
And then,
um,
my friend Max Linsky who runs longform.org or having tea and he said,
well why didn't you like push the recurring ones more?
Cause it's working really great for us.
And at that point I had the option,
but it was buried somewhere on my donation about page or something.
And so I was like,
okay.
So I put it in the sidebar and that was the one to say maybe 2011.
Um,
and it started,
uh,
crying slowly.
And so this past year when I did my taxes,
I very reluctantly went to deal with all the paypal tools to get the data out.
It's basically,
and I actually had Lisa pull all the excels and whatnot,
and then I did the tally to see,
and to my surprise,
the recurring ones,
which are very small individual amounts.
Actually we're two to one ratio to the one time donation.
Wow.
And I don't know at what point it tipped over,
but I think because of the scale and just how many people have these tiny,
tiny donations that they contribute every month.
I mean that's such an active commitment and it's so generous,
you know,
that they add up and I,
my guess is that as time goes on,
because the recurring ones have only been available for the last like two and a
half,
three years,
whatever they would become by far the larger sort of,
uh,
financial support compared to the single ones.
Sure.
No,
that makes sense.
Uh,
the,
if you had to choose,
and of course this is hypothetical,
but if you had to choose two of the amounts to leave in the dropdown,
so you've $7 a month,
$3,
$10,
25.
If you had to choose two of those to leave up,
which would you choose?
Oh,
I have no idea.
I'm probably just the mathematical,
logical choice.
The two middle ones,
it,
they're the three and 10.
Okay.
Cool.
No,
just very curious about this kind of thing.
I think,
uh,
think you've approached the blog in a very authentic way with the content and I
can't emphasize strongly,
strongly enough what you just said,
which is you,
you base what you do on what you would like or dislike as a reader.
In the case of the,
you know,
something with,
with texts,
it doesn't have to be super complicated.
It doesn't have to be doing tons of analytics for months before you make a
decision.
Just ask yourself,
would this annoy the shit out of me?
If so,
don't do it.
What?
I love this if,
so try it out.
And
every decision too has been that way.
And actually in the last couple of years I've been getting really annoyed.
I mean brainpickings is a pretty sort of low fi site as you can see it just
very,
super simple,
basic.
But I've been getting annoyed that it doesn't load very well on my iPhone when I
want to look at something or pull something up to reference or,
and my friend Scott Belsky who runs the hands,
he's a great guy and he's been sort of a very generous donor,
just supporting and you know,
and one time,
uh,
he pulls me aside.
There was like a thing in February and March and she was like,
you know how much I love brain pickings but like
the site sucks.
She didn't say it in that way,
but
sweet about it.
And the key offered to connect me with this guy that he knew that I could hire
to do a responsive design.
And I always have this resistance to making these sort of technological
improvements because then I feel like I don't want to be a media company,
like I don't want to be a buzzfeed,
but at the end of the day I as a reader and as a sort of engage or would that
experience with being annoyed by it myself.
So now I'm in the middle of releasing like a simple responsive site that is
actually easy to read on your phone.
And so yeah.
Is this fair and frustration prevail?
Again,
innovation
so,
so worth it.
It took me,
let's see,
it only took me three Oh god,
seven years to get a,
uh,
a mobile version of the site ready to go,
which I just launched a month or two ago.
So better late than never,
I suppose.
Uh,
well Maria,
this has been a blast.
I,
uh,
I really appreciate you taking the time.
Uh,
if someone were to want to explore brainpickings uh,
what,
what are a few articles you might suggest that they start with?
Um,
oh,
a few posts.
Well,
since we talked about it so much,
it's the Seneca peace about the shortness of life.
It's fairly short team.
Um,
there's a piece I did a couple of years ago which was less about,
it was not about a specific book,
just sort of things that I've been thinking about for a long time.
This disconnect between purpose and prestige and why we do things right.
Um,
I forget what it's called.
I think it's called how to do what you love or some other,
how to find your purpose and do what you love.
And it was sort of an assemblage of thoughts on that from various sources as
well as my own.
And perhaps most of all a piece that I wrote last fall as on the seventh,
the seventh birthday really at the site were,
which was about seven things that I learned in those seven years of reading,
writing and living,
which is a great article and I didn't want to replicate everything in here.
So I,
I sort of,
uh,
bobbed and weaved around some of these subjects a little bit,
but just to reiterate something that you mentioned does,
and that's doing nothing for prestige or status or money or approval alone.
And I just want to quote Paul Graham here,
which you included,
which is prestigious,
like a powerful magnet that warps even your beliefs about what you enjoy.
It causes you to work,
not on what you like,
but what you'd like to like,
which I think is so astute.
And,
um,
in closing
and also I should just interject and say any Alan Watts piece a nod.
My writing about it is so great or it's not coming from a place of checked me
out.
It's coming from a place of check him out.
Alan Watts has changed my life.
I had written about him quite a bit.
Uh,
so highly recommend any of those articles.
Cool.
All right.
brainpickings.org is the site guys,
check it out.
Um,
Maria,
any parting advice for,
for this,
uh,
episode,
this portion of our conversation?
But before we,
before we check out any advice to the people listening out there?
Thoughts,
parting comments?
No advice per se.
Just I guess a comment and an,
an and a hope,
which is that,
you know,
thank you so much now just for having me,
but for having this show and for doing everything that you do and I really hope
we have more people who operate out of such a place of just,
I guess for lack of better word,
idealism and conviction and um,
yeah,
thank you for setting any samples that way.
Oh,
well that means a lot coming from you and I think,
I think you're a tremendous force for good out there in the world.
So I hope people check out your work.
I hope you continue to do what you're doing.
I hope you continue to add repetitions to your pull ups
and uh,
we will,
uh,
we will talk again soon.
Sank.
Thank you so much for being on the show.
Thank you.
Thank you for supporting the sponsors of this show.
99 designs,
which is your one stop shop for all things graphic design related,
go to 99 designs.com forward slash Tim to see the projects that I've put up,
including the mock up,
some drafts of the book cover for the four hour body Ex-officio Ex-officio and I
go way back ex-officio dot com forward slash.
Tim,
you can see the clothing that I've used for traveling through 20 plus countries,
including underwear.
By the way,
that's about half of my underwear drawer right now,
ex-officio dot com forward slash Tim you can also see the viral video that I put
out,
which shows you how to travel the world with 10 pounds or less.
As always,
you can subscribe to this podcast on iTunes and you can find all of the links
and resources from this episode as well as every other episode by going to four
hour work week.com forward slash podcast spell it all out,
or you can go to four hour work week.com and just click on podcast feedback.
If you have feedback,
I would love your thoughts,
anything at all,
who you'd like to see on this show,
ping me on Twitter at t Ferris.
That's twitter.com forward slash t,
F,
e R,
r,
I s,
s or on facebook@facebook.com forward slash Tim Ferriss with two r's and two s's
and until next time,
thank you for listening.